Content routing concerns how to direct clients to a
particular server. One might do this in a number
of ways. One could use the routing system, for
example, Anycast. So one could number all of the replicas
with the same IP address and then rely on
routing to take the client to the closest replica
based on the routes, that the internet routers choose.
Routing-based redirection is simple but it provides the service providers
with very little control over which servers the
clients ultimately get redirected to, because the redirection is
at the whims, of internet routing. Another way to
do redirection is application based. For example, by using
an HTTP redirect. This is effective but it requires
the client to first go to the origin server
to get the redirect in the first place, increasing
latency. The third, and most common way that service
selection is performed is as part of
the naming system, using DNS. In this approach,
a client looks up a particular domain
name, such as Google.com, and the response contains
an IP address of a nearby cache.
Naming base redirection provides significant flexibility in directing
different clients to different server replicas. So in
summary routing based redirection is simple but its
very coarse. Application based routing is also fairly
simple but it incurs significant delays which operators
really care about as well as users. Naming
based redirection provides fine-grained control and its also fast.